[Applause]
[Music]
microalgae may be taken either as a
nutritional supplement in the form of
powder contained in tablets or mixed
with other ingredients to create tasty
and enticing foods
the question is how does the consumer
feel about this product that is creating
different taste sensations
professor raimundo and researcher
oliveira both work on ways to get this
healthy and natural product on the
market more
we know exactly what the consumer trends
are and we try to develop products which
meet the current consumer trends
for example sustainability simple labels
products that have a story behind them
like this one and products that have
direct benefits for health and
well-being
often when we get the consumer involved
we use children
children are very adept at trying new
things
[Music]
i think the average consumer still
doesn't have the greatest love of
seaweed it's a product that we don't
usually eat in our daily routines it's a
taste that you acquire and you have to
practice that
i think if the consumers try it they
will like it
[Music]